[Music]
this is what all sides say they wanted
to avoid
[Applause]
Sight and Sound of tens of thousands of
nurses on strike for us to come out
today you can see all nurses they're
happy not because of anything they're
happy because they now they have a voice
and strength in is in numbers
like the larger we are the more they
will have to listen
for months the Royal College of Nursing
and the government have been deadlocked
over paid in working conditions it's a
tragic day for the NHS the NHS has been
run down by this government and left in
a crisis what we're trying to do today
is to actually save our energy and NHS
the health sector Steve Barkley says
demands for a 19 pay rise aren't
affordable and would impact Health
Services he's sticking with a proposal
offered by the independent pay review
body if we were not meeting the
recommendations in Thor I'm sure ABI
asked as to why when there is a
independent process we haven't followed
that we have and it's important that the
trade unions do as well so there's no
room for negotiations well there is room
to discuss as I say a wide range of
issues because there's many issues that
impact on those things but we've have
followed the independent pay review
process
is where we should have been today and
yesterday Neil and Roni mounta are used
to delays the pandemic has meant it's
taken nearly two years for Neil to be
diagnosed with a rare form of blood
cancer he's now started treatment but
his appointments this week have been
delayed due to the nurses strike Roney
who works for the NHS is sympathetic to
the nurse's cause but knows every delay
could be costly between the the train
strikes and
the RCN strikes
it's it's not good for nail it's not
good for me it's not good for our
children we're still not sure of what
the actual prognosis is but they are at
least you know trying to treat nail and
to make him more comfortable
and at the moment he's not
hospitals where nurses have voted to
strike have had to plan ahead as best
they can to minimize disruption to their
patients we're working with all of our
staff to work out how we can recover
after each of these each of these days
but obviously you know if there are
increasing numbers of strikes that will
have an increasing impact
the nurses here do not want to keep
striking but unless their demands are
met or at least considered they say they
have no other choice some 70 000
appointments had to be canceled today
and this is only the beginning of the
industrial action with every strike day
tens of thousands more patients will be
affected and they'll all need to be seen
at some point all of this builds more
pressure on the NHS
and with a 7 million strong waiting list
that is growing all the time something
or someone will need to give before it's
too late
Ashish Joshy Sky News at St Thomas's
Hospital in London